la course est lancée les concurrents
partent à la chasse au maillot jaune
un pondra bicloo était l'une des
animations de la fête du vélo
rambouillet faut les former dès le plus
jeune âge pour avoir des futurs
champions mais aussi
bah voila je pense que le vélo à une
belle perspective dany d'avenir on n'est
ni juste par hasard faire un petit tour
dans le château on s'est retrouvé à voir
toutes ces animations cas on a passé un
petit peu de temps avec nos enfants
c'est sympa les animations et tout c'est
sympa et puis on a un petit loulou lac
est en train de s'amuser sur le manège
activités virtuelles draisienne pour les
plus petits démonstrations de vtt trial
le public a aussi pu tester une
quinzaine de vélos particulier certains
sortis tout droit de l'imagination de
passionner les vélos rigolos ce sont des
vélos qui sont modifiés
techniquement c'est à dire qu'on modifie
les caractéristiques on joue au niveau
des roues des directions des chaînes et
tout ça de manière à proposer des vélos
différent de ce qu'on a l'habitude de
rencontrer et sous une approche ludique
et amusante
un week-end à deux roues organisée par
le département département est une terre
de vélo et se veut est une terre de vélo
l'idée c'est de
c'est d'avoir une culture vélo sur sur
le département et les illilois m ce
mobilité ce mode de déplacement doux
c'est aussi c'est aussi ça le vélo c'est
à la fois du sport loisir mais aussi un
mode de déplacement
rambouillet les yvelines multiplie les
animations autour du vélo depuis le mois
d'avril prochain grand rendez vous avec
les professionnels
le peloton s'élancera du château le 28
juillet prochain